wenn die schulen wenn die kitas zu haben
dann einfach home office machen und die
kinder nebenbei betreuen das war die
anleitung der politik in dieser krise
wie das konkret aussieht wenn diese
theoretische anleitung auf realität
trifft das beobachtet heute morgen mein
kollege peter hell er ist bei familie
hase in hellersdorf peter also wir sind
hier gerade in der unterrichtsstunde bei
familie haase wir haben kurz nach neun
die kinder sind schon seit einer stunde
quasi an den schulbänken wir sehen die
ältere tochter und wir sehen ältere
tochter leann und wir sehen vater rené
haase die jeden morgen mit den kindern
schularbeiten machen die familie besteht
aus sieben kindern der älteste ist jetzt
in der berufsschule und ansonsten muss
man ganz ehrlich sagen die familie
befindet sich in der fünften woche quasi
diese kasernierung der ausgangs
beschränkung und die familie fällt
langsam die decke auf den kopf und ich
will einfach mal den vater fragen herr
hase wie sieht es aus im moment was
wünschen sie sich im moment von der
politik mehr offenheit mehr information
die kinder fragen jeden tag an können
wir wieder zur schule man hat keine
antworten man findet im internet nur
irgendwelche gerüchte feld news wie es
heutzutage heißt einfach mehr in den
nachrichten direkte ansagen so weit sind
wir wir überlegen noch dass man wirklich
informationen krieg damit man diesen
diesen look gar nicht erst glauben
schenkt man muss nicht immer direkt eine
antwort haben einfach zu sagen wir
wissen es noch nicht wir denken jetzt
darüber nach ob wir dann und dann auf
machen einfach wirklich offenheit
klarheit für uns weil es wird langsam
echt eng die beschäftigung der kinder
wird immer schlechter
wir gehen zwar jeden tag aus aber es
halt immer mit mehr schwierigkeiten
verbunden
dann frage ich bei die kinder aaron was
wünscht ihr euch am meisten jetzt ihr
seid jetzt fünf wochen fast quasi hier
in ihrem kinderzimmer
was vermisst ihr ich habe mich gerne
weiß birgit lange wagen und dann kann
man sich ja im feld oder wohnung locken
und draußen ist es warm und dann muss
man mal wasser und da schwimmhalle
richtig das ist weil wir du bist jetzt
auch bis in der ersten klasse was was
fahren wirst du am meisten denkt der
wärmere tage sind denn wirklich schlecht
mal den pool wieder aufbauen und ich
freue mich echt die schule meine
freundin wir also man merkt dass die
kinder natürlich jetzt auch wirklich
sehr traurig sind
wem es ist natürlich schwierig den zu
vermitteln was die politik jetzt macht
etwas interessanter sieht es natürlich
eben auch aus berlin denn sie machen sie
sind 15 jahre als sie machen jeden tag
hausaufgaben auch mit den kindern wie
ist ihre persönliche situation sie
stecken auch mitten in prüfung
ich kann hat jetzt weiß nichts über den
prüfungen bescheid weiß nicht wann sich
das unter den corona und alles war die
schulen wieder öffnen
der mann auch risikokinder solche die
kein risiko kennt er denn ich bin selber
ein risiko kennen und weil ich halt auch
nicht immer so direkt wie mich auch
damit umgehen soll wäre ich jetzt wieder
in die schule gehe mit dem bus auch ist
ja auch immer hat eine andere situation
wenn er wieder voll wirklich die ganze
schule mann hat einfach keine klarheit
man weiß nicht mehr wie man auch üben
soll
zuhause ist es echt anstrengend mit
kindern und alles weil das zu machen
wenn man selber nicht mal sehr viel
macht für die schule und dann halt auch
denkt man und hab den usa nicht mehr
aber dass man dann nicht in richtung
abitur
dagegen kann und seinen traumberuf hat
auch nicht dann weitermachen kann
also man sieht die probleme sind
unterschiedlich aber alle haben
denselben wunsch sie möchten alle so
schnell wie möglich wieder in das
normale leben zurück das ist glaube ich
der wunsch unser aller und wir können
nur hoffen dass die politik heute weise
entscheidet und dass die situation für
die familie
in den nächsten tagen und in den
nächsten wochen sich verbessern
moritz peter hell vielen dank und auch
vielen dank an familie hase dort in
berlin hellersdorf